[MUSIC PLAYING]
FIONA YEUNG: Good morning.
Welcome to Prototyping
to Production--
Bridging the Gap
with a Common Tool.
You made it to the
final day of I/O 2017,
and we hope you've been
enjoying your time here.
My name is Fiona Yeung, and
I'm an interaction designer
on a material design team.
DAVID YANG: Hi, everybody.
I'm David Yang.
I'm a UX engineer,
and I work with Fiona.
FIONA YEUNG: In my
world, as a designer,
I aim to give users the best,
most delightful experience
with any product I'm designing.
I create meaningful interactions
that are easy, yet exciting
that help get the user to their
end goal in as few steps as
possible.
Behind the screens,
I'm constantly
in and out of design
brainstorm sessions,
working closely with a
large variety of people.
DAVID YANG: As a UX engineer,
I take Fiona's designs,
ground them in reality,
and implement them in code.
So let's imagine we
have our weekly standup
between designers and engineers.
Fiona is going to show me
some new designs that she's
made and stuff that we're
trying to implement.
FIONA YEUNG: Hey, David.
DAVID YANG: Hey, Fiona.
How's it going?
FIONA YEUNG: Good.
How are you?
DAVID YANG: Not bad.
FIONA YEUNG: I wanted to show
you this new Kangaroo Safari
Valley card I designed.
DAVID YANG: The design
looks pretty good.
I wouldn't call
it a card, though.
To me, it's more like a box
with a three-pixel border
radius, a light black box
shadow, and a gray background.
FIONA YEUNG: It's a really
simple material design card.
DAVID YANG: Well, this
is how I'd code it up.
Everybody knows code is a truth.
FIONA YEUNG: Well, you
know, material design,
you should probably
read up on it.
It's Google's design language.
DAVID YANG: I know.
I know.
But I'm really busy, and it's
summer, and I want to have fun.
So this might-- this
is a perfect microcosm
of the gap that's seen
often between designers
and engineers.
We come from two
different worlds.
We have a different-- we
have different backgrounds,
and we have different frameworks
about thinking about things.
So we have the same
thing on screen
and we have two
different views of it.
FIONA YEUNG: When designers
and engineers meet,
sometimes it's hard to
get a consensus because
of our different backgrounds,
perspectives, and priorities.
There are times when
I'm in a meeting
and I think that
everything I'm showing
is pretty straightforward.
But then I realize that I
actually lost the engineers
a few slides back.
So even though we're working
towards a common goal,
sometimes it still feels
really hard to speak
the same language.
DAVID YANG: And because we
don't speak the same language,
sometimes this leads
to misunderstanding.
And eventually, misunderstanding
can lead to distrust.
So you have a lot
of friction when
you try to get any idea from
design to implementation.
Everything really feels
like an uphill battle.
Ultimately, it's
the users that lose,
because you lose focus on them.
You're not able to iterate as
quickly to achieve your end
goals, and you might not fully
implement the entire design
vision.
So what's the problem?
We're not speaking the
same language here.
And today, Fiona
and I will give you
a glimpse of how
we try to attack
this problem on our team.
We leverage a
prototyping-centric workflow
using the same tool, the
Flutter UI framework,
across prototyping and
our production code
in order to bridge this gap.
FIONA YEUNG: We hope to
break down some barriers
so that you can leave
this talk with a deeper
understanding on how
to better collaborate
with your entire
team, ultimately
creating a better product,
better team culture, and better
work efficiency.
We'll go over the existing
workflow between designers
and developers, for
a mindset to have
to bridge this gap, the
power of prototyping,
my personal journey to
coding, and we'll end it off
with a live demo using Flutter.
DAVID YANG: All right.
Let's dive into the
workflow between designers
and developers.
FIONA YEUNG: As you
might already know,
the design process
has several stages.
It begins with understanding.
First, you have to
understand our users.
What do they want?
What's the current problem?
And what's wrong with
existing solutions?
After we understand this
research, we begin to sketch.
This is where we generate
a ton of different ideas
before narrowing it down to
a select few for designing.
The ideas that actually
make it to the design stage
are then mapped out from
low to high fidelity
before prototyping.
And prototyping is not
only great for developers,
but it's great for designers so
that we can test and validate
our ideas.
After several rounds of
this, we refine and iterate.
So we have really
rough wireframes,
lo-fidelity mockups,
which are just
simple boxes for photos and
text placements, and then
hi-fidelity mockups.
This is what we want our
final designs to look like.
Once we get to
hi-fidelity mockups,
we create redlines. lines.
And this is what we've
typically done in the past,
but we find that it's
not the best way.
So redlines, or
what we call spec,
a basically detailed
design document
that indicates the type
sizes, color swatches,
and margin and padding units.
And this is not a great
way, because if we create--
if we treat this process like
a back and forth hand-off,
it creates a lot of friction.
As the designer, I
create the redlines,
and it takes a lot
of time, and then
I hand it off to my
developer, and he'll say.
DAVID YANG: You know,
this is really hard.
I don't think it's feasible.
Let's just switch it
up and make it easier.
FIONA YEUNG: Which means I
have to go back to my designs,
make some changes,
redo the redlines,
and it's just over
and over again,
handing it off to
my developer again,
and the same thing
happening again.
DAVID YANG: Ultimately,
these comprehensive redlines
are exhaustive, both for the
designers and developers.
As a designer, you have to
cover every nook and cranny,
so you have some padding
here and margin there.
And your developer
is bound to come back
with all these questions.
What happens is
you end up building
a lot of redundant artifacts
that are just thrown away
in the process.
There's another thing.
These mockups don't convey the
animation, transition, and flow
that oftentimes
really make a UI pop.
So we lose a lot of
fidelity through this gap
and through this transition.
So before we jump into our tool,
let's talk about some simple
mindsets to keep that
start to bridge this gap.
The first one is we
have to be user-focused.
This is important
for developers.
So developers out there,
talk to your designers.
Ask them about the use case.
Ask them about why are
you building this UI
and what's the end
objective for the user.
That way you can understand
the overlying goals
and have a clear communication
with your designers.
FIONA YEUNG: It also
helps engage together
early and often.
Designers and developers,
don't silo each other out.
Being on the same page
about expectations and goals
means that you can
still redirect early on.
It also helps to treat
it less like a hand-off
and more as a group effort,
because ultimately, it
will result in more viable
outcomes and less churn.
As a bonus, if you involve
engineers early on,
it means that they're less
likely to reject the idea.
DAVID YANG: And it's also
important to establish
the same building
blocks early on so you
can build on top of each other.
So Fiona and I should
agree what a card is,
and use that from that point on.
FIONA YEUNG: Designers,
you also need
to understand
technical constraints.
We have to know what
kind of information
we have to work with, the
data, the API information,
as well as the technical
limitations of the framework.
In order for this--
this helps us prevent us
from creating fantasy mocks that
I might become too attached to.
All right.
So we've talked about
four different mindsets
to bridge this gap.
What about a hands-on
method to improve this?
DAVID YANG: Well,
hopefully, a lot
of designers out there in the
room are already prototyping.
And you realize the
power of a prototype,
because you're able to
convey your design in a more
visceral fashion that developers
can understand as well.
The good news is there's an
influx of prototyping tools out
there in the marketplace.
They're highly
expressive, and they
make it very easy for
designers to create
these interactive flows.
But we still have one problem.
These prototyping
tools don't use
the same language across
prototype into production.
So what might be easy to do in
your prototyping tool actually
might be hard to
do in production.
And what might be hard to
do in your prototyping tool,
actually might be very
easy to do in production.
So as a designer, when
you're prototyping,
you might not
understand and explore
the full technical constraints
of your problem space.
Additionally, if Fiona
cooks up some prototypes
with these tools and
gives them to me,
I can't just copy and
paste it into my code.
So we have the same problem
as we had before, i.e.
she either has to make redlines,
which we know are exhaustive,
or I have to go and
eyeball the margins
and paddings of these
prototypes, which
just isn't ideal.
So to solve this
problem, our team
has embraced this UI
framework called Flutter.
It's an open source
UI framework.
Both our design and
engineering team
uses Flutter for our prototypes
and our production code.
FIONA YEUNG: What's
great about Flutter
is that it allows for
rapid scaffolding.
You can design fully for your
intent for both iOS and Android
platforms.
Our goal is to make
it easy for you
to go beyond the limitations
of stock toolkits.
And Flutter does this by
having composable components.
It's also built in with
a rich set of widgets,
like iOS amateur
design guidelines,
like the card and the grid
list that you're already
familiar with.
Also, Flutter has an app--
a gallery app for you to explore
the different widgets that
are already pre-built
for you to explore.
But that's not all.
Flutter gives you the
freedom to be unique.
You can design fully for
both your-- for your intent
for both iOS and
Android platform.
And Flutter does this by
using composable components
and the ability to code
with a single codebase.
Design once, code
once, ship it to all.
DAVID YANG: And
hopefully, as a designer
you realize it's
important to test
your designs in the real world.
So what does it mean to be real?
Well, you want to hook your
designs up to real data,
try to give it to real users,
and go through real workflows.
Because Flutter is one tool that
can span from design prototypes
to production, it can carry
you through this process.
It has all the developer
goodies that we need,
such as automated UI testing
framework, and IDE support.
The cool thing is teams both
inside and outside of Google
are shipping apps today on
iOS and Android using Flutter.
FIONA YEUNG: Everything David
said sounds pretty good.
But as the designer, the
thought of the coding
is still really
overwhelming and scary.
Let me walk you through
my personal journey
of learning how to code.
So prior to learning
Flutter a few months ago,
I never really
touched much code.
I had a few HTML and CSS
classes back in school,
but that was pretty much it.
I couldn't really get myself
past the long lines of texts.
And to be honest, whenever
I did think of coding,
I thought of "The Matrix," which
is really confusing and just
not accurate.
But luckily, I had a
really supportive team.
DAVID YANG: Our engineering
team wanted our designers
to come in and
take some ownership
over the small things, such as
margins, padding, and color.
And so we actually held
a series of workshops
to teach our designers Flutter.
Instead of focusing on
the intricacies of code,
such as syntax and
inheritance, we just
really focused on
the building blocks
that designers would need to
create common UI patterns.
FIONA YEUNG: So my first
experience with Flutter
actually didn't involve any
technical coding at all.
I simply learned drawing
boxes, representing
columns and rows, which
are some of the building
blocks of Flutter.
So I learned that when objects
are stacked, it's in a column,
and when they're side by side,
it's wrapped inside a row, just
like this.
And then I also learned
that you can wrap rows
inside a column as its
children, and vice versa.
So my first time actually
creating a mockup prototype
was for this simple
recipe mockup.
So on the left, we have recipe
information, and on the right,
we have an image.
So these two things
are side by side.
So that's how I knew it
belonged inside a row.
Diving
Deeper into that
recipe component,
there's the title,
description, ratings.
And because ratings has
the icons on the left
and reviews on the right, it
meant that it was side by side.
So this was going to be
a row inside this column.
And lastly, we have icons.
The icons are also
side by side, which
meant that they are
going to be in a row.
And all of this,
because it's stacked,
meant that it was going to
be wrapped inside a column.
So this was what I
did every single time
I wanted to code something.
And because I was a
beginner, it really
helped me map out and
visualize my designs.
And it was a literal one-to-one
mapping into the code.
So I would start with a
column, inside the column
were its children.
So in this children, I
would have a text for title,
description, a
row for the icons,
and a row for the ratings.
DAVID YANG: What was
awesome was not only was
Fiona's exploration and sketches
useful for the designers
on her team, it was eye-opening
for the engineers on our team.
It gave them a glimpse
of the mental model
of how a designer
approached Flutter
and how a designer
approached UI layout.
They were really
energized by this,
and in response,
they actually created
a tutorial, which was entirely
based off of Fiona's work.
And this is all live
on the Flutter website.
Another one of our designers
came from a web prototyping
world.
So he was used to
using HTML and CSS.
In order to help him
along the process,
he created a series
of cheat sheets
that mapped HTML code to Flutter
code to map these concepts.
And just like before, in
response, the Flutter team
found this really
insightful, and they
published a
full-fledged tutorial,
basically taking
his cheat sheets
and showing-- helping web
developers or web prototypers
move from the web to Flutter.
What this really shows is it
shows the collaborative power
of being on the same language
and using the same framework
across engineering and design.
Because of this,
we're able to have
these serendipitous
collaborations, such as this,
which produces artifacts that
are useful for everybody.
FIONA YEUNG: So
what really helped
me was to create
flashcards and guides,
things that resonated with how
I understood these concepts.
I also asked for help
a lot among my team,
and also I use Stack
Overflow, which is
a Q&A site for coding topics.
And lastly, just
keep practicing.
And remember, you're not
trying to become a developer.
There's still a ton
of technical things
that I don't understand
myself, but that's
the part-- that's not
the most important part.
This is just bridging the gap
between you and the developers.
All right.
So we finished talking about
the problems and some solutions,
let's dive into our prototype.
Today we'll show you how we
used the Flutter UI framework
to create this music mockup.
And we'll focus specifically
on this Featured Artists card.
DAVID YANG: All right.
Let's jump to the code.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
DAVID YANG: So what we
have here is IntelliJ,
and IntelliJ is Flutter's
officially-supported IDE,
so you're going to see
some nice things in here.
As I mentioned before, or
as we mentioned before,
Flutter's built on top of
these composable components.
We call them widgets.
So typically, you'll use simple
widgets, such as text, images,
icons, rows, columns,
compose them together
to form more complicated
widgets that ultimately
result in your end UI.
And what Fiona is
going to do is she's
going to use these basic
widgets to code up the concerts
mock that you just saw.
FIONA YEUNG: So for my
mockup, we begin with a card.
It's really simple.
I'm just going to type in card.
And then inside here,
we have a new column,
which is the stack of items.
DAVID YANG: And here we see
something really awesome.
All Fiona needs to
do is type in card,
and she gets a
material design card
with all the padding,
shadows, and background.
So it starts to
show that Flutter
is designed to be
easily scaffolded
for your common designs.
And because of that, we can
speak the same language.
Now we both understand
what a card is,
because a card is in the code.
FIONA YEUNG: So the first
part of this card is a photo.
I've already
pre-coded this part,
and I'll just paste
it right in here.
OK.
I want to remove the commenting.
And check this part out.
DAVID YANG: Flutter
uses the Dart language,
and because of that, we get
all of the developer tools
from Dart.
Fiona is actually
using Dart format here
to make her code all line up.
And this is extremely
powerful as a designer,
because you don't
want to focus on tabs
versus spaces or alignment.
So with the click of a
button, her code is formatted.
And it eases the communication
between me and Fiona,
because this is just
something that we don't
have to worry about anymore.
FIONA YEUNG: And
because I'm a designer,
I really like to
visualize things.
Just looking at the
code doesn't tell me
what I've actually done.
So one of my favorite
things about Flutter
is the Hot Reload tool.
So there's a little
lightning icon here.
With the click of a
button, I can instantly
see what I've created,
which is this photo.
I also can see that there's
no margins or paddings.
So let's go in and add that.
DAVID YANG: This part makes
you smile as a developer,
because what Fiona
is doing is she's
taken ownership of the
small design details
that she cares about.
So she's setting the margins.
And because she wrote this
code, if later on, she
decides the margins
don't look right,
she can easily go
back and tweak them
without having to talk to me.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
So with the click
of a button, now
there's margins, the
spacing around the photo.
Next up with this card, we
have the "Nonch Harpin" text.
So again I've
pre-coded this part.
And we're just going to paste
it right under the photo.
So That's all wrapped
inside the children.
OK.
Autoformat, and then Hot Reload.
And now we have the text.
So everything was
almost ready, except we
don't have the styling.
So let's go in
and add that here.
DAVID YANG: Flutter has these
objects called themes and text
themes.
They allow you to enforce
a consistent style
throughout your app, which is
very powerful for designers.
And because Flutter wants it--
Flutter's designed to be
easy to make beautiful apps,
it comes from with
material design
and iOS themes all built-in.
So terms such as
headline and body2
are all really
familiar to Fiona.
So again, we could start
speaking the same language,
and we're on the same page.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
So I've added the text styling.
Now we're just missing
the Purchase button.
Let's go in and add that.
So right now, I'm
using a raised button,
which is right out of the
material design guidelines.
And let's see what
it looks like.
OK.
We have a simple
gray one right now.
Now I click on it.
There's already a ripple effect.
And this is all built-in, so
I don't have to do anything.
And because I'm the one who
designed this design, I can--
I know that I want to
use a shopping cart,
and I know I want
the button to be
pink and the icon to the white.
So let's add that.
What's also really cool
is that when I type icons,
I see a list of built-in
material design icons
already, so it's not hard to
just insert whatever I need.
I know that I need
the shopping cart.
So let's add that.
And same with colors.
I want white.
I want the button to be pink.
Let's double check.
There.
Now the button is
exactly how I want it.
And also, if you notice
on the left-hand column,
we have a box for pink,
white, and the shopping icon.
So they're just more visual
indicators of different things
that I've used.
How's it look, David?
DAVID YANG: Pretty good.
Well, actually, now
that I look at it.
There's one small issue.
FIONA YEUNG: What's that?
DAVID YANG: Well,
according to material.io,
when you have a
card, you always want
to use a flat button
instead of a raised button.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
David caught me.
So apparently, you
can't use raised buttons
on the material design card.
So I can really
easily swap this out.
So instead of my raised button
here, I can use a flat button.
And just like that, the
shadows are now gone.
And if I want to change
this for an iOS version,
I can easily do that
right here as well.
And there's just a red box here
to show that it's an overflow.
But that's OK because
we're going to stick
to the flat button today.
OK.
Now the button is
exactly how I want.
But there's one last problem.
The spacing with the
text is really close
together right now.
What can do about that?
DAVID YANG: I would actually
use the visual debugger
in this situation.
What the visual debugger
does is it shows you
how margins, padding,
and alignment are used
to determine your final layout.
So what we have here
is we see that the band
name, Nonch Harpin, is getting
squished by our button.
And we really want
to have that text
space out for that entire row,
so we push our button flush
right.
FIONA YEUNG: OK.
So that means I need to
use an expanded widget.
So right here, expanded.
I'm going to wrap
this column inside.
So this column is
what the text is.
So I'll just put it here.
And voila, the first
part of the card is done.
Now I'm going to hand off
my code directly to David,
and he'll be able to
build right off of it,
using exactly what I've created.
DAVID YANG: And
hopefully you saw
the power of having
a really great IDE
and having a framework,
Flutter, that is
designed to be design friendly.
And so it was really
easy for Fiona
to add her icons and
buttons and change things.
OK.
So now I'm going
to-- let's pre--
I'm going to check
out Fiona's code.
So she gave me some files, and
I'm going to check that out.
Oops.
Try that again.
OK.
Let's give it a run and
see what it looks like.
So Fiona has actually
gone in ahead
and created out the venues
detail section, which
is on the bottom right here.
So it shows that we're going
to this Nonch Harpin concert
at McKillop's Bar.
Cool.
Now let's take a
look at the code.
So I've gone in
ahead and started
making the code a little
bit more production ready.
So I extracted out her
UI into this widget
called the Artist card,
which specifically
represents this entire card.
As you have seen,
maybe in Fiona's code,
things started to get
a little bit long.
We were nesting a lot of things
inside columns, inside rows,
inside columns.
So in order to make this
a little bit cleaner
and semantic, I built
these helper functions.
So we have the
buildHeader function,
which just rebuilds
the widget that
represents this top section.
And then we have the
buildVenueDetails function,
which just builds this
bottom part right here.
And finally, we put these two
functions inside a column.
So again, it shows
that everything is
really composable in Flutter.
They're just functions.
What's really important
for our workflow
is the fact that I've only
moved around Fiona's code.
I didn't really
change it at all.
So this is still Fiona's code--
oops-- and she can go back and
make changes, if she wants to.
So Fiona, what do we want today?
What are we looking at?
FIONA YEUNG: So when
I tap on Nonch Harpin,
I want the venue details
to close or expand
whenever I tap on it.
DAVID YANG: OK, cool.
So we want this card
to be toggleable
so we can expand and
close the venue section.
First, I'm going to make
a Boolean flag, which
is my state, and this will
tell me when to open the card
and close the card.
By default, we'll
make the card closed.
The next thing
I'm going to do is
I'm going I want to animate
this opening and closing.
Flutter has a widget built-in
called the animated crossfade.
Now, what this does is it
animates between two widgets.
So my first widget will
be the venue section.
So I'm just going to copy
and paste this venue details
function, plop it
in my first child.
And then, because I'm opening
and closing this card,
my second child is just going
to be an empty container.
So I'm animating from
something to nothing.
Finally, I have to
specify based on my state
when to show the venue details
section and when to hide it.
So when open is true, we'll
show the first widget.
And when open is false,
we'll show the second widget,
which is the empty container.
All right.
Great.
Finally, we want to specify a
duration for this animation.
Right now I'm just
going to eyeball it,
maybe make it 400 milliseconds.
But the cool part is
because Fiona and I are
using the same codebase,
we're using the same language,
if Fiona thinks this
doesn't look good,
she can go back and tweak it.
So I'm not too worried here.
All right.
Let's see what it looks like.
So what we have is
we have the card--
the venue section
details is hidden.
And that's because by
default I set open to false.
Now I actually want to
hook up a user action
to toggle this state.
Again, because Flutter has a
lot of material design widgets
built-in, it makes it easy
to make this look nice.
I'm going to use a widget
called the Inkwell.
What the Inkwell does is it
shows a material design ripple
every time a user
presses on that section.
And now I can perform an
action based on that touch.
So we're going to move all
the content of the card
inside that Inkwell.
Give it onTap callback.
And let's see what we get.
Oops.
We have an error.
That's fine, because I
put it in the wrong place.
Let's put it right here.
There we go.
So when I tap it, I get
my material design ripple.
Finally, I need to hook up that
action to change the state.
In this case, it's
pretty simple.
I just set--
I just toggle my Boolean value.
So open will be toggled.
All right.
Nice.
We get this nice animation.
And it looks pretty good to me.
FIONA YEUNG: It looks pretty
good, but there's one thing.
DAVID YANG: What's that?
FIONA YEUNG: It's
a bit too slow.
DAVID YANG: Oh, yeah,
go ahead and change it.
FIONA YEUNG: So because
I'm familiar with this now,
I can just go right
ahead and change it.
So let's try 200 milliseconds.
That's a little better.
DAVID YANG: Yeah, great.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
Can we switch it back
to the slides please?
DAVID YANG: So
hopefully, this gave you
a little snippet of the
advantages of working
within the same language.
Using the same tool from
prototyping to production,
we're able to jump
in, collaborate,
and I think we have a better
working relationship now.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
So let's take a look at some key
takeaways from our talk today.
One of the reoccurring themes
that we've been talking about
is embrace the same language.
Embracing the same language
allows you to actually
be able to communicate
with each other
with fewer misunderstandings.
And you're able to
work better together,
creating a more
user-centered product.
And ultimately, you also
become more empathetic
towards each other.
DAVID YANG:
Hopefully, you've seen
it's really a two-way street.
It's a group effort.
So designers need to take the
jump, dive into some code,
and learn some of
these technical tools.
But on the flip
side, the developers
need to embrace design, and
also help their designers come
to this world of coding.
It's not easy, and requires--
and as you've seen,
our team has held these
workshops to get this going.
And it's pretty apparent
that it's a process.
So to be honest, it took
a lot of upfront effort
for our team to
get this through.
It took a lot of
work and workshops.
But I think, and we think
that this work is well
paid in the long run and it's
going to benefit your team.
You're going to iterate quicker.
Your designers and
developers are really
going to collaborate and
like working with each other.
FIONA YEUNG: And lastly,
we can't stress enough,
but aim to use a common tool.
In our team, we use Flutter.
But lots of things work for you.
As long as you use
this common tool,
it helps you break down
these walls between you
and the developer or
designer, and bridges
the gap between you guys.
DAVID YANG: So hopefully,
you saw the problem,
we're not speaking
the same language,
and you had a glimpse
of how we tried
to approach this in our team.
The really cool part
is all that code
that we showed you in
that mockup, that was
all a real project on our team.
And that stuff's all been
committed in our repos.
So it's a real example.
Finally, if the tool we used,
Flutter, really interests you,
I'd recommend going
to this talk at 10:30
by our coworkers
Emily and Emily.
This is a more technical
talk, and they're
going to build an app full
out in front of you for iOS
and Android on the same time,
hooked up live to Firebase.
And the best part is that
because we're Google,
this app's going
to be a chat app.
FIONA YEUNG: All right.
So if you need more
available resources,
we have a lot online,
Flutter.io, materialdesign.io.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Design newsletter.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID YANG: Hang on.
FIONA YEUNG: One last thing.
DAVID YANG: Yeah, and
if you're interested,
if you have more questions
about Flutter and our workflow,
we'll be out there in the
patio, answering questions.
And we'll also be giving
out some Flutter swag.
So hopefully, we'll
see you guys later.
Bye.
FIONA YEUNG: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]